say
well definitely will create more red
flag laws in what opponents say is just
the latest step towards enacting more
restrictions on law-abiding american gun
owners the bill will do nothing to
prevent future school shootings this is
a classic case of feel goodism symbolism
over substance and i expect as much from
the democrats but it's the republicans i
have a problem with here and they're
going to spin this this bill is going to
be focused on mental health who's
against helping people that need mental
health help
anyway and they're trying to spin the
excuse on the red flag law well it can
only be temporary you might have a
chance to lift it later and when the
next school shooting happens with a
different weapon what are they going to
do then how about we give every school
in america undercover armed trained
retired police officers and military
have one way in the school one way out
emergency plan got for business of fire
have every kid go through a metal
detector the same protection in other
words that we give elected officials and
hollywood stars that have all the
security in the world that are armed
anyway one of the few senators talking
sense on the republican side is texas
senator ted cruz i'll be honest senator
um you know i i listen to your fellow
republicans
it's beyond disappointing that they are
involved put their names up on the
screen uh because this isn't going to
work because let's say
tell me how this is going to prevent the
next school shooting your bill with
senator barrasso would go a long way to
doing that none of them are doing a
thing to protect any kid in any school
that i
see well sean i agree with you and and
tragically we've seen the same pattern
play out over and over again
every time there is a horrific mass
murder there have been far too many of
them i i was in yuvaldi the day after
that horrific attack when that
psychopath murdered 19 children and two
teachers and it is horrific we need to
stop them
but instantaneously when there's a
criminal attack a mass murder we have a
debate in washington and there are two
approaches
one approach is target the bad guys
target the criminals target the violent
felons and those with serious mental
illness who try to illegally buy
firearms prosecute them put them in jail
get them off the street and keep people
safe and that also includes protecting
vulnerable places like schools and
churches with police officers that's an
approach that works that's an approach
that makes sense
the other approach the approach of the
democrats is to try to take away
firearms from law-abiding citizens to
try to go after the second amendment
rights of law-abiding citizens and that
approach is unconstitutional but it also
doesn't work it's completely ineffective
in stopping violent crime and so this
particular bill that we're going to be
voting on this week i think is misguided
i think it's a mistake you mentioned the
red flag laws
those red flag laws provide an
opportunity to disarm law-abiding
citizens
in many states with a very low standard
of proof with little to no due process
protections
and and and i think that is not going to
prevent violent crime but it is going to
make people more vulnerable and less
able to defend their homes and their
families
just today i introduce legislation
with john barrasso that is it's called
the cruz barrasso legislation and it's
focused on stopping violent crime it's
focused on funding prosecutors that if
you commit a violent crime with a gun
you're going to be prosecuted by the
department of justice and sent to
federal prison if you try to illegally
buy a gun if you're a felon or fugitive
and you try to illegally buy a gun
you're going to be prosecuted and sent
to federal prison and this bill provides
36 billion dollars
for funding over 10 years for police
officers armed police officers and
schools it doubles the number of police
officers in schools it provides 10
billion dollars in funding for mental
health health counselors so if you have
a kid that has serious mental health
issues you stop him early before he
commits the crime
this is the approach that makes sense
and critically
my legislation cruz barrasso
doesn't infringe in any way on the
second amendment rights of law-abiding
citizens it's targeted at the bad guys
and it keeps you and me and the rest of
us safe i hate i hope people call their
senators we put the republican names on
the screen and let them know you don't
support this legislation so we have this
january
6 committee with a predetermined outcome
from the get-go and it's the bludgeon
donald trump
they have sworn testimony under oath
that donald trump authorized two days
before january 6 up to 20 000 troops be
called in now that's required by law
then the jurisdiction at that point goes
to nancy pelosi muriel bowser the mayor
of d.c the mayor of d.c in writing
declined to call up the troops
on we know three days before the six the
capitol police chief based on new
intelligence he started requesting the
guard troops to be called up and he was
denied
why haven't they looked into why they
didn't why they did not take it
seriously knowing we came off a summer
of 574 riots by the way where's the
committee investigating that
and now we know that there are direct
threats we're probably going to get a
decision on roe v wade this week
if we get that decision this week there
are groups that are calling for people
to riot we reported on it last night
what is joe biden what are these big
cities doing to protect people in light
of a threat that we now know is public
well let me start with with where you
ended which it which is i think the
supreme court the next week is going to
issue its decision i think it's going to
overturn roe versus wade that's the
right decision
end this week
uh they could do it next week so so it
could be tomorrow it could be next week
we don't know for sure when the when the
opinion will issue but it's soon it's
it's within the next few days
um that's the right decision that will
return the question of abortion to the
elected legislatures that's where the
constitution
left it that's where it belongs but i
think the response is exactly what you
said which is the organized left they're
going to engage in riots they're going
to get engaged in violence we're going
to see a reprise i fear of the black
lives matter and the antifa riots where
they're going to try to use
political violence to advance their ends
and the department of justice needs to
step in and stop them i halfway expect
the attorney general to be rioting
alongside them because this department
of justice has been so politicized now
you mentioned in the first part of your
question the january 6
so-called select committee hearings this
thing is a joke this is not a
congressional hearing so congressional
hearing is designed to be a fact-finding
mission it you you have opposing sides
this is a political democratic campaign
commercial and let me just ask you this
question what would you think if you had
a criminal trial and the judge said okay
we're only going to allow the prosecutor
to speak
only the prosecution can call witnesses
the defense doesn't get to cross-examine
those witnesses and and we are only
going to present one side of the story
that's what nancy pelosi is doing well
if you want
a campaign commercial if you want to
prevent it from happening again uh you
probably should look into the question
is why they didn't call up the troops
that's the guy that they're claiming
wanted this to happen authorized but
they don't want to talk about that all
right senator no opposing view
appreciate it as always